bonsoir
à tous ravis d'être parmi vous
il est là bernard arnault non y'a que
des pme
c'est pas grave j'ai l'habitude de
m'adapter à mes auditoire pour vous dire
j'étais encore hier au japon avec des
gens comme carlos ghosn ou autre bon
déjà est-ce que vous avez des questions
concernant les précédentes interventions
parce que je serai en mesure d'y
répondre
non alors je me présente je suis un
scientifique michel ladi un entrepreneur
j'ai inventé beaucoup de choses
je suis notamment le père de la
mammographie par satellite
le principe il est simple certains le
connaissent
la patiente pendant une demi heure mais
ses seins nus à la fenêtre de son
appartement
le satellite prend des clichés qui sont
transmis directement médecin référent la
carte vitale est coincé entre les seins
et lui lui automatiquement avec à la clé
plusieurs millions d'économies pour la
sécurité sociale
alors je reviens aux interventions
d'aujourd'hui j'ai trouvé qu'elle était
plutôt intéressante
mais je voulais aller plus loin et je
sais que vous les petits commerçants
vous avez des problématiques bien
spécifique que je vais essayer d'adressé
ce soir joyce je sais pas comment vous
dites en français
un mot sur mon parcours quand j'ai
commencé ma vie professionnelle je me
suis intéressé moi aussi au financement
des études des jeunes
j'avais un projet de crowdfunding et en
creusant un peu je me suis aperçu que 92
% des étudiants qui n'avaient pas obtenu
deux prêts bancaires n'en n'avait en
fait pas demandé n'en avait pas besoin
partant de ce constat j'ai décidé de
m'intéresser à autre chose
et je me suis intéressé à cette question
des révolutions française qu'est ce que
c'est les révolutions française pour moi
ce sont d'abord les gens qui
réfléchissent un par opposition à ceux
qui ne réfléchissent pas comme vous j'ai
la chance de faire partie de la première
catégorie et j'ai fait un constat c'est
que les gens qui n'ont pas d'idées
et bien il y en a beaucoup alors je
cherchais depuis longtemps un moyen de
rassembler ces gens et j'ai eu l'idée de
créer des plateformes en open source
rapidement on s'est rendu compte que
quand on met en relation des gens qui
n'ont pas d'idées
ils n'ont pas plus d'idées mais ça les
occupe
ça les occupe et ça c'est intéressant
c'est à la suite de ça que j'ai créée il
ya quelques années un festival
qui fédère ces gens qui n'ont pas
d'idées il y en a parmi vous qui ont
déjà participé à ce festival
non bon c'est bien on est entre nous
donc après ce premier succès je suis
devenu consultant on a parlé tout à
l'heure des limites et des barrières
mon approche est sensiblement différente
quand mes clients sont confrontés à des
limites ou des barrières
je leur conseille de faire demi tour
parce que dans l'autre direction il n'ya
généralement aucune limite
et ça c'est très grisant
alors regardez plutôt mois que l'image
derrière parce que le temps que le flux
vidéo arrive il ya un petit retard donc
si vous voulez être en avance c'est moi
qu'il faut regarder
pas la recopie vidéo je vous donne des
petits type street
ces cadeaux un rien ne vous sera
facturée
une intervenante a parlé tout à l'heure
de la pédagogie du fait religieux dans
les établissements scolaires ça m'a
touché parce que l'année dernière je
suis moi même allé dans les écoles
primaires et en interrogeant les enfants
je me suis rendu compte qu'il y avait un
autre tabou que le fait religieux
ce sont les retraites et dans la bouche
des petits la même question revenait
tout le temps quand et combien
a déjà pour nous c'est compliqué alors
imaginez pour les enfants donc sur ce
sujet il m'est apparu important de
libérer la parole des bouts d'choux et
de faire de la pédagogie
1 qu'est ce qu'une retraite à taux plein
qu'est ce qu'un point de retraite à
trimestre valider un trimestre réputé
cotisé etc etc donc faire de la
pédagogie et surtout faire tomber les
préjugés chez les enfants un toi tes
parents y cotisent à la préfon burke et
10 balance des noms de caisses de
retraite à la figure arrco agirc tout
mais savent pas ce que ça veut dire
et à force de pédagogie on obtient un
respect mutuel toi tu crois qu'une
caisse de retraite complémentaire n'est
pas nécessaire moi si et on peut vivre
ensemble
un peu libre ensemble car on a au moins
un point commun c'est que nos pensions
ne seront pas revalorisés
et derrière on crée du lien on partage
le goûter etc
j'ai complété ses séances de discussion
par des ateliers une fois par semaine
pour dédramatiser un si on peut avoir la
vidéo annoncé peut-être pas là
dédramatiser et familiariser les enfants
à l'idée d'un troisième et quatrième
âges
aïssi dans une école pilote à nous donc
ça ça m'a occupé toute l'année dernière
et je me suis un peu reconnue dans
l'intervention de tout à l'heure donc
bravo à je voulais dire un mot
maintenant sur l'élevage de mouches
puisque je travaille sur un projet
similaire depuis quelques années mais
comme je suis plus avancé dans le
processus je sais que l'autre
intervenant fait fausse route
ça fait partie du plaisir de l'avant
turin c'est agréable c'est le chemin
c'est pas la destination
donc moi aussi j'avais choisi les
mouches au départ et finalement je me
suis tourné vers les éléphants pourquoi
parce qu'il n'ya plus à manger et en
plus ils s'envolent pas donc tout est
plus simple mais restons sur les mouches
pour que les idées soient plus claires
le ce cycle qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
il comporte des déperditions d'énergie à
chaque étape et mes recherches montrent
que le site serait moins énergivores si
on chantait
si l'homme n'accepte de manger
directement de la merde
ce serait beaucoup plus éco responsable
déjà en fichent la paix aux mouches
qui n'avait pas demandé à être associés
à nos problématiques
et en plus on maigrir est un peu car
l'expérience montre que quand on mange
des détritus
on en mange moins là sans toi mais là
encore là encore il ya de la pédagogie à
faire à passer d'une côte de boeuf à du
lisier ça ne se fait pas comme ça d'un
claquement de doigts et les incitations
fiscales ne suffisent pas on le sait
alors dans ce modèle qui dit beaucoup de
détritus dit beaucoup de rats et de
souris et à terme la souris a je crois
une carte à jouer pour se substituer aux
boeufs si on prend une souris qui a pu
se rassasier de gruyère un mois je les
appelle les souris salers et bien on
n'est pas très loin du boeuf en termes
de goût alors vous avez vous dirai
comment fera quand ils rapide fromage et
bien il faudra trouver autre chose et le
futur à mon avis c'est de manger des
souris auxquelles on a inoculé le rêve
le souvenir d'avoir mangé une bonne
figure
parce que vous le savez il ya une
transitivité du goût par le rêve voilà
pour ce sujet pour votre information
sachez que depuis deux ans on marque
discrètement tous les spectateurs de la
conférence avec un élément radioactif
léger et après leur départ du châtelet
on visualise leur mouvement voilà un
grâce à une caméra gamma c'est le
principe de la scintigraphie et qu'est
ce qu'on apprend grâce à cette
technologie
c'est que vous n'habitez pas tous au
même endroit ça fait partie des
applications des ntic
il faut pas en avoir peur
malheureusement malheureusement malgré
les efforts de clarté et de pédagogie
des différents intervenants
on se rend compte que dans la durée ce
qui est mémorisé par l'auditoire est
assez faible
moi je vous emmène péniblement un sommet
de connaissances et après c'est la chute
douze heures après la fin de la
conférence il n'en reste pour ainsi dire
rien
et trois jours après la plupart des
spectateurs en savent encore moins
qu'avant et une partie oublie même
qu'elle est vue
c'est les fameux 30 40 % qui ont oublié
de revenir cette année s'agissant des
quelques-uns qui se souviennent de
quelque chose
en général ils mélangent tout et à cela
je voudrais leur dire
par pitié s'il vous plaît ne cherchait
pas à résumer ce que vous avez entendu
aujourd'hui pour l'image de la
conférence tedx paris
vous l'avez compris ma passion c'est
d'avoir toujours un coup d'avancé
c'est un peu ma grande spécialité là en
ce moment je travaille sur deux projets
assez ambitieux le projet le premier
projet c'est un projet qui s'appuie sur
la bioluminescence c'est un écran plat
sans électricité ou les led de la dalle
sont remplacés par des lucioles drogués
des lucioles sous crack
bon pour l'instant on est sur des
résolutions de 220 lucioles x 90 mais on
progresse vite et mon deuxième chantier
c'est une voiture écologique fabriqué
tout temps quinoa y compris le moteur et
quand la voiture arrive en fin de vie
on peut la manger et ça c'est un facteur
d'acceptabilité sociale
1 d'après moi la révision et beaucoup de
problèmes de mise au point un résistant
des structures aux intempéries mais le
projet est viable
j'en suis quasiment sûr
donc on aura des occasions d'en reparler
merci